there's a trend on youtube on facebook
right now is that there are videos
and there is no purpose to that video oh
yeah
and you're waiting
to see what the end of the video is to
see what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
at the end of the video the guy is doing
nothing
like a complete waste of time
it's so absurd
like this without seeing the video it's
hard to know what that's like okay so
what it is well last video i saw like
that i was pissed off after watching it
it's a guy
there's a toilet bowl and he has a a
drill and he's poking four holes
six holes in that the cover of the
toilet and he's putting a tube in those
holes and he pours a gatorade in the
tube
and it goes
inside outside inside and in the toilet
no purpose
the troll in me appreciates it no
purpose so you're there watching this
[ __ ] like what's he gonna do but you
know what
that that is some of the best
performance art in the way because as
you are browsing this app for no [ __ ]
purpose yeah here's some content that's
going to remind you of how [ __ ]
polite this is
and it's actually impactful yeah because
i saw that as i was browsing i'd be like
i need to delete this you know but
you're like you're right because i was
watching that and i said
all right i gotta get on with my day and
take a shower yeah
yeah
what the [ __ ] am i doing right now i
gotta get on how did you even find that
video that means that so many people
watched it and were disturbed by what
they saw it reflected something in the
emotions let me see if i can find it
because we go to facebook for a payoff
and here's a video or a content piece of
content that tells you like there is no
payoff
no there's no reward there's none
there's not why are you here and i don't
know to me there's just some poetic
about me no i don't find the video
there's something really cool but it was
yeah it was just oh my god what a
[ __ ] complete waste all right i got
to get on with my day yeah i got out of
bed and i went to take a shower it
motivated me so i guess there's a
purpose for that but just to remind you
that
you ain't doing [ __ ] right now and
there's something better that you should
be doing those minutes you're never
gonna get yeah never gonna get never
gonna get it never gonna get never gonna
get it never gonna get never gonna get
it never gonna get it
[Music]